venez aussi alors ce qu'on aime aussi
idiot ni aussi il y avait une petite
boulette comme tout le monde
donc on a vu celle du dakar qui était
très drôle il a toujours appelé en 2012
lors d'un concert il a dit sur scène
quelle joie d'être ici avec vous à
clermont ferrand et à saint-etienne
il a tellement bad pour y arriver à
plusieurs artistes là on en parle ce que
réalise et ça je pense que c'est assez
courant fait maintenant dans l'est je ne
sais pas si ça date de sa boulette mais
maintenant quand on est en tournée sur
les murs on a des feuilles qui nous
indique où ils catherine où elle est là
où sont hébergés tout ça et on a aussi
des feuilles qui existent ici nous
sommes comme ça tu risques - te tromper
soirée avant de monter sur scène
ici nous sommes alors lord unitaire lors
d'une interview aussi la déclarer une
phrase magnifique regarde que vous les
connaissez ces joueurs de football
j'en connais quelques-uns bon bien sûr
je connais je connais déjà gibbons jeu
c'est bien au jour le jour et la suite
de la phase 2 je vis au jour le jour à
plus bas non mais regardez regardez ça
c'était je vis au jour le jour pour
demain pas pour hier et il ya aussi en
93 il avait un esprit très logique
il a déclaré pour faire un couple il
faut être deux et c'est vrai qu'il a
même là dessus mais n'arrive pas parce
que c'est des geôles avait pris comme
une collègue et ami ils s'aiment bien
été utilisé la vérité